[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice christy wright number one
best-selling author a couple of times
over ramsey personality is my co-host
today her new book take back your time
the guilt-free guide to life balance is
a number one bestseller just came out a
few weeks ago so be sure you check that
out we'll be taking your calls today
about your life and your money you jump
in the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
jordan starts off this hour in portland
oregon hi jordan welcome to the ramsey
show
hey dave how are you doing today better
than i deserve man what's up
good well dave i
doubt you remember me but i spoke with
you i believe in april or may of this
year
uh and i'm coming back to share some
great success uh you know i i
sold my property i had back in denver um
my wife and i were just getting ready to
get married and
now that's happened the house is sold
what it's paid for we're debt free
uh we put a down payment on a beautiful
house we're getting ready to close here
at the end of december beginning of
december great and um yeah it's
fantastic it feels like a huge
accomplishment and you know it
definitely had its ups and downs when we
got back from our honeymoon i actually
lost my job
so a little hiccup but i'm glad that we
had that you know our guests taken care
of and now i'm back to work making more
than i did before and my wife's got a
job that she wants to and
um
we're i feel bad though um all things
considered things are going pretty well
i
went through this buying process
of this this property i mean we found
this house together
but when it came to paying for the house
it all came down to
my credit and for the mortgage um you
know my wife's
didn't have good enough credit to be on
the mortgage with us but she's you know
an equal owner of this property with me
uh but now that you know we're debt-free
we're getting ready to close on this
house she kind of admitted it to me
today that she felt a little bit left
out of the process and she wants to be a
little bit more involved with finances
and
i feel bad that you know i didn't really
take that into consideration beforehand
i'm looking for some guidance from you
all and to see you know what can i do
better
to help make sure that she's involved
with this process and
and how we can
you know how i can get her acclimated to
what the finances look like if that
makes sense
well it's interesting jordan because
what comes to mind for me this this
house buying while it's super exciting
and yes it's a big deal it is
one step
one piece of your financial journey what
i what jumps out to me that is way more
important is that your wife is involved
in the day-to-day finances in the
monthly budget and the conversations
where you guys as a team come together
and say hey what are the goals we're
working on and how are both of our
values represented and both of us have
equal ownership and equal um
you know responsibility and that that to
me is what makes the
unity piece so powerful in relation to
your marriage when it comes to finances
buying a house is a is a one-time thing
like that happens it's gonna you're
gonna close when you close and and i i
mean i can see how she would feel that
way if there was some type of
conversations in those meetings where
she felt shame or less than or something
and that's something that you know is
valid and i'm glad that you're you're
asking and i'm glad that you care um but
i would not see that continuing to be an
issue i'm just guessing here but i
wouldn't see that continuing to be an
issue day to day in your marriage and
managing your finances dave i don't know
i don't know if i'm missing a piece of
this i think you're there
to christy's point
doing a detailed
budget before the month begins and both
of you agreeing on that
sharon and i've been married 39 years
and if we are agreeing on our calendar
and we talk calendars like we talk
budgets matter of fact maybe more detail
on calendars these days
and um and we're agreeing on our budget
and we've agreed that neither one of us
make large
financial decisions without the other
one involved
and including giving including
uh buying something i don't come home
with a new car and go look what i did
you know i mean we don't do that um we
talk about anything we're going to buy
before we buy it that's pretty simple
and um you know now it may be that
she's redecorating
and i'm just like okay
what are we going to spend we're going
to spend x all right i'm good with that
now then she goes and does 9000 details
associated with that but i'm in the loop
enough that i i didn't get surprised by
the
sticker shock of uh us redecorating
again
and so um
but uh uh but yeah so are maybe i'm
buying a toy uh or something and i'm
going hey you know this is what i'm
looking at doing are you okay with this
yeah and then she doesn't have anything
else to do with it i go do it so you but
but she's in the loop on the decision
and the monthly budget the rhythm of
where the money's going around the house
what we're doing with that um that puts
it all together so
i'm kind of with christy i kind of think
you're not doing that part if you're
doing that part it'll probably solve the
big part yeah the one thing i would add
to that is you're talking dave because
you make such a good point of the other
person being in the loop on the decision
even if they're not gonna
have an interest in necessarily
redecorating of the toy or whatever they
know about the purchase and one of the
things that matt and i have put in place
years ago is we just simply
do not make any type of financial
decision until we are totally on the
same page and i know that's probably
common sense for you and i but i want to
say it out loud because some people
might just be like oh well and they go
ahead and do it and it's showing respect
to the other person to hold on any big
decisions on any decisions until you
guys get on the same page and so um so
be willing to work through that those
type of conversations
that's what's going to create the unity
in your marriage
that's going to make a big difference
jordan so it could be that you kind of
she said yeah let's get a house you went
and got it
and she wasn't involved in the process
enough
as far as that goes and she's actually
gonna live there
so uh whether she's on the credit or not
you're on the credit doesn't matter to
me at all that's not part of this
conversation so
good question thank you for joining us
zachary is in sacramento hi zachary
welcome to the ramsey show hi sir how
are you today great what's up
hi uh quick question for you i've been
watching a lot of your videos recently
on youtube and my brother recently got
me involved with uh with a lot of your
stuff
uh and i'm just trying to to understand
my debt snowball um
and what
the the most current video that i've
watched on your on your youtube was uh
zero percent apr or credit card to
tackle your debt
um and what i have actually tried before
uh i i don't have one okay i gotta stop
you i'm confused
you did not see a video with me telling
you to get a zero percent credit card
no no i'm sorry it was uh
the the title was zero percent it was a
military um
family they they had um opportunity uh
through their
uh status to have zero percent apr on
their credit card but uh the way that
i'm saying it is um earth i guess my
question would be for you um
is if i have the opportunity to get
uh uh a credit card at zero percent apr
for 15 months
uh currently i have uh one credit card
what's your what's your balance on the
card currently
my my current credit balance uh that i
owe is about six thousand dollars okay
and the interest rate is what
it's 24
okay
and so you're gonna save 300 a year
300 is not your problem sir
your problem is getting on a budget
living on less than you make and getting
six thousand dollars paid off 300
doesn't fix your problem you can move it
to zero percent if you want but you're
still gonna be six thousand dollars in
debt you're still not getting the rid of
the debt you didn't you didn't pay it
off you moved
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality
number one best-selling author of the
brand new book take back your time the
guilt-free guide to life balance ramsey
personality is my co-host today hey we
got a question for you is it too soon to
start talking about christmas
i think it is
talking about it our marketing team does
not think it is talking about it no
we're getting we're getting so close
dave i think it's christmas all the time
i know i'm that guy you are but every
year we celebrate christmas with our
ramsay show listeners with a ramsay
christmas cash giveaway
and
yep i mean halloween's gone so we gotta
go it's happening game on right we gotta
start giving away money it's a tradition
this year we're giving away five hundred
dollars a week and a grand prize of five
thousand dollars you can enter every day
to increase your chances of winning of
course no purchase is necessary must be
18 years old to win
text cash to 33 789 our famous 10 sale
is out there on 40 of our best selling
books including the total money makeover
and christy wright's 2022 goal planner
is not 10 but it makes for a makes for a
great gift uh
we're about a heart attack there
i was like
i sent him the wrong notes no no
everything a bunch of our books are ten
dollars including total money makeover
rachel's book new new book know yourself
know your money from number one
bestseller from last january is um as
well but the gold planner is out and we
don't have a bunch of these left uh they
set you up for the all of 2022
talk about what the gold planner is yes
and this is actually it is on sale i
believe for 40 so it is on sale from its
normal
sale price of 49.99 but here's what's
cool um this is really we were talking
about this today but it's actually
really five products in one because it's
got some content like a book would have
it's got journal questions like a bible
study or journal would have it's got
templates and worksheets to help you
grow in the areas that i'm teaching you
and it also of course has your calendar
your weekly monthly calendar and it's a
goal setting tool but if you want to see
the inside i did a live walkthrough
today
on my instagram page and on facebook so
instagram is at christyb wright facebook
is at official kristy wright and you can
see the entire inside and i train you on
how to plan your year using any calendar
but of course i'll walk through the goal
planner so you can see this one because
after all christy be right
and if you don't believe me ask matt so
here it is
there it is
so i walked up to the restrooms at the
uh
golf course that i was at in mexico the
other day and it said uh men to the left
because everyone knows women are right
not a bad sign i like it not a bad
chicken that's funny i like it open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five the calendar the ten
dollar books and the cash giveaway all
at ramseysolutions.com be sure and check
out
all of that at the store there at
ramseysolutions.com jim is with us jim's
in knoxville hi jim welcome to the
ramsay show
hey how are you doing dave great man
what's up
all right i'll keep it kind of short and
to the point
been a listener for a while and
i've heard a lot of calls relating to
careers and things like that
but i've not been one on this situation
that i'm in
about 10 years ago
due to
some substances
and partying i became a felon
and
to keep it very short and concise
i can't stand the job i'm at
and out of the last
50 applications that i've put in every
one of them has for a job every one of
them has come back as a no so i was
hoping maybe you
as a business owner and a leader could
give me some advice on that yeah you're
always going to get a no on applications
you've got to get your foot in the door
with somebody you know ken coleman
teaches that
um and in his book the proximity
principle
so let me go back
what you have to have is you have to
have a narrative a story to tell that is
the truth
that explains the situation to a
reasonable person
okay
so
you got busted for drugs what happened
yes okay um yeah i got a dui when they
pulled me over
i didn't have a concealed carry permit
and so i got a charge for that
and the because of that and apparently i
was being stubborn that night i don't
remember to be honest with you um but
how long have you been driving charged
with penalty uh let's see that was oh
how long have you been dry 2012 october
of 2012 october 2nd okay so you haven't
you haven't done drugs or alcohol since
that's correct okay
and uh you were how old at the time
i just turned 21.
okay
and so you're 30 right
just turned 31 a few weeks ago but yeah
okay
so um
the way i would do this is just to bring
this up fairly early in the process so
you got a friend that works over at so
and so and they'll get you in to see the
boss for an interview you go in and sit
down and go listen i'd love to work here
but i won't be really up front with you
way back in my 20s 10 years ago i was
partying i've been drive for 10 years
but i got busted and so i've got a
felony and if that if that's a deal
killer because of 10 something 10 years
ago in my past i just want you to know
up front and if you said that to me in
an interview i would say well let's just
keep talking i appreciate you bringing
it up but i want to know more about you
and i'm not going to rule you out based
on that
if you're a child molester 16 months ago
you're out of here i don't want to talk
to you anymore
that's me okay but a rape but most of us
did something in our 20s we're not proud
of and hope nobody finds out about in
your case everybody found out about it
that's correct
yeah and the other thing i i i love the
the advice you gave dave of if you have
the conversation explaining the context
around it you don't tell them your life
story but giving some context because
when people hear the word felon they can
jump to conclusions and that title
encompasses a lot of stuff even as you
told us like when you were telling your
story you said well i did some drugs and
i just turned 21 i was like oh
my my my initial thought was oh okay
well that's not that bad you know i mean
it's like it was 10 years ago it was 10
years ago and so i just think that
people will
hear you out when you give context
around that just like you said dave
you'd say well but if you're in a pile
of a thousand resumes and they're trying
to narrow it down the first thing
they're gonna do is just call out the
felons yeah yeah they're not even
they're trying to get down to one or two
to interview okay but you've got to get
in the door with someone that you know
which by the way is what we teach people
that don't have this situation still the
same exact information king coleman says
you have to get in the door with someone
you know let me give you an example okay
if regardless of your criminal
background right
we have 30 something thousand
applications coming in to ramsey this
year
for 350 jobs
the chances of you getting out of that
stack
period
is obviously statistically very low
unless you got a friend that works here
or a friend of a friend that works here
that runs down to hr and says hey at
least give this guy a look
and that's that little bit of connection
of who you know and it's not that they
get the person the job because that
never happens here
it's that they get them a look and they
get out of the stack and they'll get you
a look and then you go in and just tell
the truth of this story it's ten years
ago i've been dry ten years but when you
look it up you're gonna find a felony
for a stupid kid that was doing drugs
back then not done anything like that
since but you're gonna find that back
there and you just move on real quick
little narrative and explain it most
people will go okay he's a 21 year old
idiot i mean that's what happened most
of us were right
and so
and they move on but some of them aren't
i mean you get some kind of corporate
goob
they've got some kind of policy they
can't break but that would not keep you
from getting hired here
so your strategy then jim would be
instead of just applying for any job
that has a position with your skills the
strategy would be let's make a list of
people we know that work at companies
that we might like to work for or make a
list of companies we might like to work
for that we might know someone at and um
and let's let's give them a copy of ken
coleman's new book from paycheck to
purpose absolutely i'm gonna send you
two books and i want you to go to ken's
website and download everything he's got
at kingcoleman.com for free as well the
book is paycheck to purpose it's the
brand new book that came out yesterday
and ken's first book which is what we're
kind of talking about here is the
proximity principle get in proximity of
the things you want to do use someone
you know to get your foot in the door
and we'll send both of those out for you
and get you going so proud of you jim
good job staying dry 10 years man that's
pretty cool that's hard to do and
obviously you've got a couple of scars
to prove it so uh you'll get there
you'll get through you'll get this to
where it's further and further and
further in your rear view mirror the
beauty of the rear view mirror is it's a
lot smaller than the windshield
the windshield is your future that's
called grace
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just 30
dollars a month get unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over 70 a month
by switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage donald and megan are
with us hey guys how are you
welcome where do you guys live
philadelphia all right welcome to
nashville good to have you how much have
you paid off uh 83 000 and how long did
that take uh 20 months good for you
range of income 113 to 177 000 whoa nice
jump in 20 months what in the world what
do y'all do for a living i'm a cpa
and i'm a project manager okay how did
you guys run your income up 40 or 50 60
grand during this time this one's a
grinder
oh okay yeah the old project manager
managed some projects yes i did all
right very cool what kind of debt was
the 83 000 uh we had student loans well
i had student loans um two cars that we
were releasing
and uh an engagement ring that i
financed oh
how long you all been married uh about
since june so what is that four months
now six oh just got married yep yeah
okay so you were working on this before
marriage separately and then you
combined everything and finished it up
exactly so tell us your story what
happened how'd you get plugged into this
ramsey stuff so we've been together
seven years and uh we got engaged four
years ago and um we you know we weren't
doing horrible but we felt like we
really weren't making much progress and
um at my accounting firm there is a
partner who is constantly going around
telling everybody to read the total
money makeover i love this guy yeah
um so he he you know i was back then i
was a little bit more ignorant and i was
i thought you know i'm a cpa i thought i
knew everything about money i'm trying
to beat interest rates by you know
making returns with stock investments
and
um
and one day i'm like you know what i'm
just gonna like like his name's roman
he's been talking to me about the total
money makeover so much and then one day
i'm like you know i'm just gonna watch a
youtube video of dave ramsey and there's
a fox business video that i show all my
friends these days um it's like 45
minutes it's the first thing that's on
youtube really yeah when you google uh
seven baby steps but anyway i'm driving
down the road i'm not even watching i'm
just listening to it and i'm hearing
your voice in the video in the baby step
two explanation and how intense you were
about being gazelle intense and paying
off that debt and
how much behavior was involved with the
paying the smallest to largest i'm
thinking you know pay the highest
interest rate so i'm like you know what
i'm gonna sell some of these stocks and
i'm just gonna do what he says and just
see how i feel i go home i have about
nine different student loans and i sell
the stocks and i paid all four of them
and in that moment that was my crack
moment of like i can do this wow wow
yeah and there and uh megan's always
been pretty good with money like
generally frugal but we never had like a
budgeting background and i
we were like we were doing this
separately but in i had most of the debt
and i was
really getting gazelle intense making
like you know i have my starter
emergency fund i have five extra dollars
in there and i'm like in the parking lot
going into work i'm like i'm gonna make
a five dollar payment like you know
every little bit matters i like we were
really like getting intense with it and
there you know we started this process
and we're like
we're getting married we want to be in a
good spot like when we get married so we
really kind of like we did it together
but we kept you know we kept everything
separate but once we were able to put
everything together
it's just been magical ever since i love
that i love that part of your story that
you're like i'm just gonna try it i'm
just gonna try selling these stocks i'm
just gonna try one little thing but when
you felt that feeling of progress you
were in and that's just so fascinating
donald because research shows that
nothing is more motivating than seeing
progress and now look at you like you
stuck with it you guys have worked so
hard every stage from engagement getting
married well done that's incredible
thank you thank you
cool so megan what were you doing while
he's going crazy over here yeah yeah
well he was going crazy i was
really just trying to learn how to
budget i was always good at
saving i thought
and then once we started to
use the every dollar app to start
budgeting and everything was more
transparent and i actually saw what i
was spending money on
i started to realize that i wasn't as
great as i thought and you know
seeing that he was so intense about it i
started to be intense about budgeting
and
it kind of went from there wow very cool
okay so you've been married how long
june june
okay so six months
and now everything collides and it has
to be combined and overlapped and then
you finish up the debt
how did that go
great
it went beautifully i mean we've really
i think we we actually paid off our last
debt like
right um
like right we we we had these leases and
once the leases were done we got you
know gave the cars back um bought a used
car we actually share it now which is
like much easier to uh much easier to do
than we thought it would be um
but uh yeah and now we're actually in a
spot that we actually or we've we know
when i was in that parking lot making
those five dollar payments like
we were living you know living like
nobody else and now we're living like
nobody else doing something different
we're actually moving to florida which
is like wow yeah it's a dream of ours to
go down there because we visit all the
time so we made this decision earlier in
the year and everything's been going
smooth since and
you know it's because we followed we
followed the process you got to you got
to really sell yourself to it you really
need to be obsessed so you took new jobs
and you're moving to florida
so i'm actually uh staying at my job i'm
able i'm working remote so i'm able to
to work okay
and i'm actually going to take some time
off um
i don't i wouldn't be able to do it
without this uh process but i plan we
plan on go down i'll be able to have the
extra time to help us settle in and then
i'm gonna start applying i love it yeah
good for you guys what city are you
going to uh st petersburg yeah great
very good guys what an amazing step to
what amazing way to start your marriage
um debt free on the same page you're in
the rhythm of budgeting now y'all are
awesome who were your biggest
cheerleaders through this whole process
absolutely
roman lashak the one that was pushing
the uh okay the the book on us um mr
total money makeover back at the firm
exactly
proud now hopefully everybody else at
the firm starts reading it um but we uh
you know even it wasn't just introducing
the book like i would ask him different
questions and he was there to support us
the whole way um
other cheerleaders our parents yeah
definitely our parents um you know
supported us the entire time and
probably thought we were crazy like the
decisions we're making but following the
process it works yeah and probably the
few people we converted along the way
yeah a couple of years so what do you
tell people overall when they say how
did you do that what do you tell them
the key to getting out of debt it's the
biggest things you did
you just gotta stick to the budget
as boring as it can be and as annoying
as it can be it is just
it is the foundation of all everything
that you do when it comes to this when
doing these baby steps
you gotta have a plan and stick to it
right
once you once you stuck with it those
first few months did it get easier like
after the first couple months of
figuring it out now are y'all in a good
rhythm where it's just it's a little bit
more effortless for sure and the the
every dollar app makes it so easy where
you can just pull over the budget from
the last month and
you know we we have it down pat where we
know what our spending is and
we just can
have the the conversations each month
are a lot quicker yeah you know what to
expect right good enough for you guys
the feeling of contentment is a big deal
i think like we used to just like buy
buy buy things that we wanted to do like
traveling and
you know buying a new xbox and things
like that but
really like if you just take a step back
and think like what makes me happy what
do i actually need this that makes
budgeting a lot easier because then you
just find yourself naturally spending
less too yeah yeah absolutely well done
guys proud of you thank you great work
great work we've got a copy of the
legacy journey for you that's the next
chapter in your story for sure on your
way to baby steps millionaires now
that's where we want you to go from here
and i think you're on your way to do
that and a copy of total money makeover
for you to become that guy that gives
away those books
i like it that's fun the legacy
continues
all right it's donald and megan from
philadelphia soon to be florida 83 000
paid off in 20 months making 113 to 177.
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream three two one
[Applause]
i love it if you want to get plugged in
with that every dollar app and go
through financial peace university and
you're thinking about this year i'd like
to actually be ready for christmas and
you want to do what she's talking about
you start doing that budget you'll feel
like you got a raise that's exactly what
they were saying you can take a ramsey
plus free trial right now just text
trial to 33
789
text trial two three three
seven
eight
nine
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
her number one best-selling book her
second one that's the number one take
back your time the guilt free guide the
life balance is on sale at
rent it's for sale at ramsey
solutions.com the goal planner for 2022
is on sale be sure and check those out
we're answering your questions about
your life and your money today luke is
with us in idaho hi luke welcome to the
ramsay show hey dave how are you doing
better than i deserve what's up
i'm good man i had a question i'm having
a baby in january yay
yeah thank you baby boy
and uh we have we uh have forty thousand
dollars in debt right now me and my wife
student loan debt
and we're also trying to pay for a house
and i was also curious my main question
is really what can i do now to invest
towards
that child's future uh it's your first
baby
yeah you're a good dad already
congratulations well done yeah thank you
well luke we teach a thing called the
baby steps which is the best way to
attack your money situation and the
shortest distance between where you are
now and wealth
okay
so we're going to tell you don't save
for a house
until you get this debt paid off we're
going to tell you don't do anything to
get this debt paid off baby step one is
save a thousand dollars
two is pay off all of your debts except
your home and that's all you've got
forty thousand dollars worth by listing
them smallest to largest attacking them
with every ounce of financial energy and
other energy you've got by the way this
is the best thing you can do for your
new baby is get your life cleaned up
then once that's clear you go to baby
step three and have an emergency fund
four as you start saving for retirement
and or if you want to put that on hold
for just a minute sometimes we do 3b and
save towards a house
five is kids college and baby step six
is then turn around pay that house off
early
and so we'll show you how to do all of
that but the trick is to do all these
things in a order if you try to do
all of it at once kids college saving
for emergencies getting out of debt uh
saving for retirement saving for a house
you're going to find you get none of it
done yeah it's super frustrating too
because you're losing money and the
interest you're paying on those debts
and you just feel like you're you feel
scattered because you are you're trying
to make uh progress in a lot of
different areas so if you do these in
the order that we teach you one at a
time you will start to feel the progress
it was like we were just talking about
feel that sense of progress and that
will motivate you to make more progress
and stick with it long term and so just
doing attacking those in that order and
then when you get that debt paid off and
you've got your fully funded emergency
fund yeah then we can look at a house
and saving for college and investing and
all that good stuff by the way you got
plenty of time to do all of it you're
gonna get there no need to panic
it just feels very urgent with a baby on
the way and that's normal that just
means you're a dad that cares you're a
good man that's all that means and
you'll get there but we'll show you how
to do it systematically and the shortest
distance it's called the baby steps hold
on i'll have kelly pick up we'll send
you a copy of the book the total money
makeover somewhere around 8 million
people have read that book so it's
probably going to be okay for you you'll
probably like it mavis is with us mavis
is in portland oregon hi mavis how are
you
hey i'm good how are you dave better
than i deserve what's up
yeah so um my question for you today is
um i am a real estate agent um so i've
been having a pretty good past few years
so um as far as the retirement is
planned i want to
ask you what is the best option so i
currently have an individual 401k that
i'm in contributing 15 of my annual
income just for the tax benefit so i'm
not sure what else
that i should have um
because you know right now i'm just
thinking about i need to save some tax
because tax is so ridiculous um so what
other
retirement plan like ross or anything
else that you recommended me opening
at this point yeah yeah so you're you're
in a 401k
like an individual 401k
you did a simple ira is that what you're
saying
um it is called an individual 401k so
like i contribute
um now what's this money being invested
in
um it's it's just a vanguard um i think
it's money market and how much are you
putting in there
um about uh
30 40 thousand every year okay all right
that should be in a roth
and i'm not worried about your taxes
if you save on taxes now you're going to
pay a pile of taxes later
so having no tax benefit now and growing
tax free
is going to end up hundreds of thousands
of dollars ahead when you get to
retirement if you if you start cheaping
out trying to get the tax break now by
doing pre-tax then the entire account at
retirement is taxable so you don't want
to do that so mavis what we'll tell you
to do is to limit your giving or you're
you're investing to 15
at baby step four making sure you have
an emergency fund in place and you're
out of debt except the house then we get
the house paid off if your house is paid
off then if you want to do more you can
sit down with your smart vester pro
there's a lot click smart vester pro at
daveramsey.com that's who we recommend
for investing and they'll lead you
through whether you can qualify i don't
know what you've done there with
vanguard i'm not positive but um
but you can do a sep uh you could do a
simple 401k you can do a roth ira you
can do all of these in roth
and there's a lot of ways to put a lot
of money aside
uh but if you're already got 30 000
going in i'm not positive you may be
doing a sep ira that may be what that is
and you're making a you're making a lot
of money if that's the case
so um in terms of in order to put 30 000
in you would have had to have had a good
income a really nice income
so that that's the uh the whole process
connor is with us in youngstown ohio hi
connor how are you
hi dave i'm doing well how about you
good how can we help
hi uh i just had a quick question about
my wife and i i am 20 and she is
23.
um anyways i'm sorry i wasn't expecting
um
we are currently
going to be needing a
new car or new car soon
why yes
so i
when i was 18 when i was 18 i made an 18
year old decision and got a lease
oh okay and it's going to be up soon
well i still got another year on it
however i went to the toyota dealer and
since the value of cars is so high right
now
they're willing to help you out are they
that's sweet of them
well
they said that they would uh
buy out of the lease and i could walk
away from it for you know no cost to me
oh really and not have to buy another
car from them
correct just because wow nobody can find
cars anymore so that's an awesome that
i'm you know considering okay however we
are still paying off debt we have our
obviously our base thousand dollar
emergency fund but
um you know we don't have any extra
money as of right now
what's your household income
before taxes it's about 90 000 between
the both of us good for you
thank you
okay and so how much is your car payment
on the one you're going to turn into
toyota
uh the lease payment is 330 a month okay
so what if you stopped everything for a
month
how much money could you pile up in a
month if you were in emergency mode
like three thousand bucks probably right
uh
maybe no not paying extra on anything
just beans and rice
in one month you're making 90 000 a year
yeah before taxes i know
right
you got to be able to get 3 000 bucks
together in a month
okay and then buy a 3 000 car and turn
your toyota in
right
and then the only other thing is so that
that's what i was considering doing and
then the only other thing is that my
wife drives uh her car is a 2012 it only
has 89 000 miles on it but it's the
volkswagen beetle and i can't stand that
car but um
regardless it you know it's had its fair
share of problems and it's
um it still runs good but i just i feel
bad having my wife in
you know the knot
you know i mean the husband drives the
crap
in general so yeah you're gonna be
driving a three thousand dollars
don't worry we're gonna get you set up
with a crap card yeah
gonna drive crap cars it's equal
opportunity crap car day equal after
equality and by the way you're 20 and
23. so these are the stories you tell
your grandkids
yeah yeah your car's running fine you're
fine she's fine get out of debt get
yourself out of that get you a 3 000 car
get rid of that lease
drive the bug drive the junker
and and roll up your sleeves and get her
done buddy you can do it you can do it
you'll be out of it before you know it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice
i'm dave ramsey your host kristy wright
ramsay personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life
and your money her latest book is also a
number one bestseller take back your
time the guilt-free guide
to life balance on sale now at
ramseysolutions.com and where any great
number one best-selling books are
sold
jacob starts off this hour in phoenix hi
jacob how are you good thanks for taking
my call sure man what's up
um i am actually going to get married at
the end of the school year um we're
going to move well she's in houston so
i'm just going to move there and finish
school
um we're kind of debating now is should
we
buy a house or should we just rent until
we get rid of
um
some debts that we have
yeah you're you're going to want to
follow the baby steps jacob and so i'll
walk you through those really quickly
because this is the way for you to build
wealth and so you want to do things in
this specific order
you want to start by saving a thousand
dollars and this is going to be your
starter emergency fund so that if you've
got you know your brakes go out you get
a flat tire you've got some cash to
cover that and you don't have to go
further into debt
then you're going to list all your debts
smallest to largest regardless of
interest rate and you're going to attack
those debts
one at a time pay them off cut up their
credit card close the account whatever
you have to do you pay minimums on the
rest and you continue to walk down
the debt snowball until all your debt is
paid off when you get all your debt paid
off you're out of school your school is
paid for in cash everything's covered
where you have no more debt then you
want to save three to six months of
expenses uh for a fully funded emergency
fund and after that that's when we talk
about saving for a down payment on the
house
we would tell you to do that anyway
jacob at any stage of life any age
but even i would just add the fact that
you're in school you're about to get
married you're going through a lot of
transition
and so you probably don't really know
what you want anyway in a house so even
if you
were debt-free i would still recommend
that you get out of school
with that without any debt and uh and
and and really figure out what you want
before you commit to a massive purchase
like that but you want to get debt free
have your fully funded emergency fund
get out of school debt-free and then um
and then and then talk about saving up
for down payment on a house jacob
there's a lot of pressure
in our culture to immediately buy a
house buy a house buy a house buy a
house buy house you're throwing away
rent you're throwing away the money
you're throwing your money down to rat
holes or renter don't be a renter don't
be a runner like renters go to hell or
something right
and so you you don't you don't want to
fall for all of that it causes people to
jump into a house because when you buy a
house and you've got no money
and you're in debt
all kinds of problems come crashing down
around your head and it's going to put a
stress on your new marriage
strain on your new marriage just rent
something inexpensive and clean up the
debt then when you don't have any
payments man
and you move into a house with no
payments and you move into a house and
after you close on the house you've
still got the rainy day fund of like 10
000 bucks or whatever it is sitting
there yeah put there's no stress moving
in the house now the home is a blessing
rather than a curse and we always say
yeah christie's right you need to get to
know each other you'll buy a different
house a year after marriage than you
will you know a week after marriage
takes about a year of being married to
know how close to your mother-in-law to
buy
this is the ramsey show open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five christy is in omaha nebraska hi
christy how are you
hi i'm glad i'm excited to talk to you
you too what's up
all right okay so my question is with my
iras i have four iras that have been
rolled over into an investment firm and
i have
one that is still in an old 401k and
they're both about the same amount
and when i meet with the financial
advisor he always tries to get me to
bring that 401k money over
but
that 401k money consistently does better
without his
um advice i guess and
it is a super low administrative fee
versus i pay about four thousand dollars
in fees with my financial advisor per
year
uh how much money do you have with this
advisor
um the advisor is
378 000. oh okay
all right
so they've got you on a managed account
they're charging you like a point eight
or one percent to manage your funds
yeah one point two five per quarter per
account
and i added it all up and about four
thousand dollars
no that doesn't that that would be four
percent and four percent of four hundred
thousand is not four thousand
four thousand is one percent of four
hundred thousand
on the statement it says no if you're
paying four thousand and you have four
hundred thousand over there you're
paying one percent
that is one percent by definition
mathematically
right
it specifically says on the statement
expenses 1.25
um and then
they're each four accounts are a
slightly different amount so i am
rounding a little bit that must be the
annualized amount then
okay because otherwise you would be
paying more than four thousand dollars
you'd be paying sixteen thousand dollars
okay
because four times four is sixteen
right one percent per quarter would be
four percent a year
four percent of four hundred four times
four or sixteen you'll be paying 16 000
right
yeah but yeah i'm not
okay and you're not you're paying four
thousand so you're paying about a one
percent fee give or take it's pretty
standard management fee so i think what
you got to do is number one
your job with your investment advisor is
not to
do whatever he says his job is to do
what you say
after he teaches you or she teaches you
something and so if you're paying a one
percent management fee it is reasonable
for you to expect that to perform
outperform an index fund by one percent
thus they're paying for themselves
yeah and you you've got it just sitting
in a basic account just running itself
over at the 401k and that's kicking this
guy's butt
so this managed accounts not being
managed well agreed
i
agree it's not getting the same yield
and
i mean it feels like a loss with that
much money i put 500 a month in so 6 000
a year and i'm paying 4 000 fees like it
just feels well that's not that's not
the relative amount what the relative
amount is is you put it in a managed
account at 378 000 and you're paying one
percent for him to manage it then it
ought to be invested meaning managed he
ought to you guys ought to be sitting
down together and picking funds
that are that are
making you more than that one percent
back
and good managed funds do that
so number one you need to sit down with
him and get that straightened out if you
can't get that straightened out in your
mind you probably ought to interview
some other financial advisors and click
like smart investor pro at
ramseysolutions.com click talk to the
folks that we recommend
a lot of those guys do manage the
accounts too the vast majority of them
do now
and so there's nothing wrong with that
it just has to be worth it that's all it
comes down to
and if it's not outperforming a basic
fund mix that you picked on your own
then he's not worth it he's not worth
paying him that
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome to the ramsey show america we're
glad you're here open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
christy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today if you've been paying
attention to the real estate market
you've noticed that it's kind of quite
hot out there yeah
competition's high
if you're trying to buy a property
available inventory is at all time lows
inventories low demand is high that'll
drive prices up it'll also make people
stand in line in the street to make
offers
sellers want to accept the right offer
buyers don't want to pay too much this
is not amateur hour people
to win in this market you need a pro by
your side
that's why we find vet and endorse
top real estate agents across the
country called endorsed local providers
they're ramsey trusted our elps
have years
of industry success we do not endorse
newbies we endorse high performance high
octane real estate agents
just a handful of real estate agents in
your area sell most of the houses
everybody else just got their license
because a monkey can sell a house right
now
and you don't want a monkey listing your
most expensive asset
although it might be entertaining
go to ramseysolutions.com
agent find a trusted agent near you
austin is in atlanta georgia hi austin
welcome to the ramsey show
hey guys appreciate your time sure
what's up
hey i was calling mostly about a career
question
i was recently uh i've been in ministry
my whole life uh recently laid off uh as
many people during the pandemic um
trying to get myself back out there i've
kind of got a limbo job i would say to
pay the bills now
um but from asking all my friends and
everyone else in ministry it doesn't
seem like
the money is quite there like it is
everywhere else in the world and what i
mean by that is like it you know
everything's getting so much more
expensive but it seems like ministry
jobs are actually paying less
so i was trying to see
should i keep pursuing this that is
really my passion or should that more so
be my side gig being your all-star
volunteer
and maybe going more into
the workforce to help provide for my
family
this is an interesting question austin
because there's
there's more to this
than just the financial equation
because of what you're asking about
and so
i'll i'll tell you something i'm kind of
uh i'm i'm learning right now austin and
this is just from from very recent for
me so i'm in seminary right now
and i'm taking a class right now on
practices and vocation formation and it
talks about how different people are
called into ministry called into
different aspects of serving and there's
a
there's a very
pretty consistent correlation where
people are called into ministry and they
feel called in different capacities in
different ways
and they're called because of the they
they pursue that they're obedient to
that because of the calling not because
of the
um compensation
and and you need to pay your bills
but i don't think that you can look at
this
question you're asking from purely
uh
just a financial lens because because of
the the faith aspect of what you're
saying
um right you know if
if you if your question is
um you're always gonna make less in
ministry yeah that
that can't be the reason you go or don't
go because that's just that's just a
given of the industry now the other
thing is this
there's um
really the last hundred years or so is
the first time in the history of
christianity
uh that we've looked at professional
ministry as the only people doing
ministry
prior to that everyone was in ministry
meaning that the blacksmith did his job
as unto the lord
the uh the restaurant owner did their
job as under the lord and the way they
treated people and the way they did
marketplace interaction was a ministry
they were ministering through their
business and through their uh vocation
without being quote professionally in
the pastorate uh there's nothing wrong
with being professionally in the past
obviously some of my best friends in the
world are that but the uh uh
but this idea that the only people that
serve god or that are in ministry are
on a church staff is a fairly new idea
uh right
and and so uh you know
the jewish mindset is the word worship
and the word workship are very similar
words of worship service on
sunday morning and customer service on
monday morning both are a service
in both cases we're having a service um
so
uh we view what we do here very much as
a ministry uh as believers
and um
[Music]
some agree with that some don't but
that's not relevant to this discussion i
it's what we do and it's who we are
so uh it may be that you are
uh you know you're being released from
vocational ministry to do ministry
in the marketplace so to speak with
wherever you land i'm okay with either
one
if you feel like you have a solid call
on your life to be in vocational
ministry to be on
you know church staff
then you're gonna make less
uh my contemporaries that run a
40 million dollar budget uh at a church
make
probably 50 60 percent of their in
of the income of someone who runs a
comparable size business and so it's not
that unusual at all
so it just kind of goes with the
territory and it's not not that it's
right or wrong but it just is
i think you bring up a good point though
because i one of the the challenges i
would have for you austin is as you
reflect on this and you think about this
and you pray about this
ask yourself
am i am i have i always been in ministry
and feel like i need to be in ministry
because that's my heart my passion
because i feel called specifically to
that
method of ministering in the church
world for example or
do i feel like i need to do that type of
work because to me that represents
somehow good work that somehow
represents work that makes a difference
and the
secular world the for-profit world
represents bad work work that doesn't
really help people a lot of people get
these mixed up and dave you and i have
talked about this when it comes to
business non-profit versus for-profit
there are people that believe that
non-profit organizations are more holy
than for-profit organizations to them
that represents a a different value and
worth and and it's so interesting dave i
mean i learned all of this from you but
i the the non-profit for-profit
designation is a tax status it's how the
money flows to the organization nfl the
nfl is a non-profit organization
so we so i would just encourage you
austin as you're reflecting to think
what am i
pursuing is it good work because you can
do good work in the church and outside
the church you can change lives in the
church and outside the church
or is it i feel called specifically to
being on church staff like you said dave
and that's a different that's a
different question just know that you
you will make less if you do that which
is fine we need people in the pulpit we
need people in churches um and god's
calling your life i really believe he'll
provide for you but but just make sure
you're not pursuing it because you think
somehow that's the only way to do good
work i believe that every one of us here
at this organization and many other
organizations um nonprofit or for-profit
are doing good work that changes lives
so that might be a good exercise for you
to reflect on as you as you think about
this yeah good question sir thank you
the other thing that was in his he said
you know i wonder if i just volunteer
it's kind of made me think his heart is
is already gone he's moved on and he's
ready to ready to have another phase in
his life so it sounded like when there's
permission for us to to change seasons i
think sometimes we are so resistant to
let go of something we don't recognize
it was a season we think everything's
forever
and so i remember when i when i felt my
heart being done serving in young life
ministry in the day-to-day with
teenagers at high schools i wrestled
with that for probably a year too long
my heart had already moved on but i
couldn't let go
that this was what i was supposed to be
doing and now we support young life in
other capacity but everything isn't
forever it might just be a season
and you have permission to change your
mind and change your plans and move into
this new season yeah and on the other
subject it is a good to remind everybody
here's the thing there's no such thing
as a non-profit organization
a non-profit organization that doesn't
make a profit is closed
they always take in more than they have
go out
it's just how they it's just an
accounting function the irs does not
decide if something's holy or not
and they do decide whether something's a
non-profit or not based on the
guidelines that they have
and so but a non-profit that's not
profitable
closes they go broke
just like a business does
so this idea that somehow they don't
make a profit is asinine
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at zip
recruiter have made the whole job search
way easier ziprecruiter is rated the
number one job site in the us by g2 and
it's free so how does it work
first go to ziprecruiter.com
ken then create a free profile and let
their technology do the hard work by
finding and sending you jobs that are a
great fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's
ziprecruiter.com slash ken sign up today
absolutely free and let zip recruiter
work for you
[Music]
go
[Music]
[Applause]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage frank
and nicole are with us hey guys how are
you good how are you better than we
deserve welcome where do you guys live
cleveland ohio cool welcome to nashville
and here to do a debt-free scream how
much have you paid off
125
563.
amazing way to go how long did that take
20 months good for you and your range of
income during that time stayed right
around 120 000.
wow y'all busted it yeah you've been
beans and rice baby something going on
here what kind of debt was this
uh everything but a time share pretty
much we had uh 401k loans student loans
car lease
credit cards tons of credit cards
medical debt on a care credit card yep
how long y'all been married two years
so you combined to make this mess
no
no no we each made it ourselves that's
what i mean you brought the two messes
together yes
you didn't do all of that mess in two
years
you've been busting it since you got
married to clean it up is what it
amounts to i think i financed my first
truck at 19 and
i have had a car payment ever since both
of you bring the junk in or one of you
both both okay all right cool
and so you've been married two years yup
in 20 months you've been doing this so
you've been doing the whole time you got
married so tell us the story how did you
get plugged into ramsay uh my mom
actually gave me the total money
makeover book several years ago
um didn't work well it worked for a
couple weeks
you know
it's a great coaster yeah
and then uh after you know getting up
every morning and checking my bank
account to see if i could eat lunch if
my credit card payments didn't clear yet
um i told her i got to do something with
this so
i kind of told her about it and we were
both kind of
back and forth with it and then i kind
of started on my own
we were hesitant to
[Music]
combine all our finances and everything
so i got her listening to the podcast
and every day i'd come home she'd say
dave says we should combine everything
um so finally we just had enough sat
down did a budget combined everything
and
within two months we were
what we're knocking things out yeah wow
i want to go back to something you said
frank because i think a lot of people
listening feel like maybe you felt back
then you said we were hesitant headed to
start the plan hesitant to combine
our our accounts what was going on there
what do you think what was how would you
describe that hesitation we we both
are on our second marriage okay um so i
don't i don't know if it was not a trust
issue between each other just
you know
having everybody you know accessing each
other's stuff was just kind of strange
at first yeah yeah that's normal yeah
yeah you're like grown-ups when you got
married you're independent you got your
everything grown up yeah yeah
something else
you know when you get married and you're
20 it's different you know because
you're right you know but but you guys
are second go around you got some scars
from before and you've been doing it
yourself a long time and now just to
combine everything feels weird it's like
doing it with your roommate or something
but yeah but then you push past that
awkwardness and was it worth it
absolutely it looks like the weight of
the world's been lifted off our
shoulders within
just by doing the budget and within two
months it was like once we got our
emergency fund it was
it just changed life yeah wow did you
sell stuff oh yeah what did you say
what's the biggest thing oh yeah
everything my harley probably
oh that hurts the nerd's frank that was
what did the harley bring i heard for
you
15 000. oh that's substantial i mean i
still had it i had a payment on it yeah
and you know we were in the program for
a few months and i
came home and said i'm going to list the
harley that's when i knew he was for
real yeah wow that's when you knew you
married a man yeah he was interested
he's willing to get rid of his bike for
his family
yeah called a man yeah that's good wow
good for you
that's hard to do but you'll get another
one oh yeah they're out there they make
them all the time oh yeah and they get a
little better every year i hear so you
never know but uh for sure wow wow very
cool what else did you sell those big
gosh we sold anything with a payment
pretty much the car fleet um the car
fleece we got a quote from carvana when
everything was they were looking for
cars like crazy we got rid of that
um
that was a 600 lease
and we actually sold it to garbana and
made a thousand a thousand dollars whoa
so we got out at least 10 months early
wow that really once that happened that
really boosted our snowball yeah that
and the harley were two big things to
move this along about 900 a month to our
snowball by getting those two items well
and that lease was how much of the 126.
uh we had it listed i think as 30 000.
yeah okay so 45 000 of 126 of those two
yeah moved out that's excellent yeah
that's harsh but it got her done oh yeah
and it got the cash moving too the cash
started moving in the budget then like i
had to start going yeah you know math
start working yep once that started
happening it was just like i said it was
just you smile every day when you get up
yeah it's different going to work when
you don't have to go to make a credit
card credit card payment yeah you get up
and you're like hey there's interest in
our account this time you know
it makes getting up in the morning
easier that's good that's really good
who are your biggest cheerleaders
through this
besides i'd say probably both our
parents oh wow so they came alongside
and said go huh oh yeah yeah now who was
a head given that had given you the tmmo
book earlier years before that was my
mother okay okay was she excited to see
you all get on this plan she passed away
about four years oh i'm sorry so that
was a little motivation too she is
excited she should be going crazy right
now yeah she's watching and she's
excited right now that's good way to go
you guys i'm proud of you good stuff
very good stuff it's very well done
very very cool so um man that's powerful
now so you did all of this off the book
and the podcast yep mm-hmm okay and
that's that was your inputs from us yep
all right good very cool all right we
got a copy of the uh well tell us what
the tell us tell everybody what the key
to getting out of debt is
working together for sure and the budget
yep together the budget i'd say
i'd had selling crap because you saw a
bunch of it yeah like my buddies used to
call me and says everything okay with
you guys your wife's selling uh what was
it selling everything your kids swim
mask from four years
scrappy work in that facebook
marketplace how much did you make how
much have you made on marketplace oh a
few hundred dollars just little things
it's spiritually representative though
yeah it's like we're cleaning up here we
laughed because we actually talked about
selling the house with this market just
talking we weren't really gonna do it
and my daughter goes over to her friends
and she's crying her mom calls me and
says you guys okay your daughter says
you're losing your house i'm like
oh we're not that bad you're selling
everything on marketplace that was
interesting i'm not that bad
oh it's so great
i love it if you're broke friends or
think you're losing your mind you're
right on track right that's so perfect
well done you guys we got a copy of the
legacy journey for you that's the next
chapter in your story you're going to be
baby steps millionaires before we know
it you'll be right there that is that's
what's coming up next and uh wow very
cool very very very well done copy the
total money makeover you can give it
away to somebody maybe they'll read it a
few years from now you never know
you never know hey thanks for coming
down guys frank and nicole cleveland
ohio 126
000
paid off in 20 months making 120 a year
they sold everything
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream three two one we're debt-free
[Applause]
that's awesome you know this car market
is allowing people that's the second
call the second people today talking
about how they got out of a lease early
and didn't have to write a check
this is the first time in the history of
leasing that that's happened yeah uh and
it's because this market's so
substantial on cars like it is on real
estate so this car market has moved
stuff around and honestly i have noticed
a trend in the last two or three years
in debt-free screams not as many people
were selling big chunky items until i
got to them today i like hearing that
yeah
the number of times people would sell a
boat a harley a car
to and it's a it's a big number out of
their number right to where it made a
big difference it's not
it's not a a few hundred dollars on
marketplace which is fine that's a good
thing to do but that mathematically
wasn't what got him there right
spiritually it got them there right but
this idea that you can sell so much
stuff the kids think they're next yeah
and the poor kid thinks they're losing
their house
that's uh
that that's that's the mentality you got
to be
going for it man i mean you got to go
for it i love it way to go you guys you
guys are fun
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality
number one best-selling author her
latest number one take back your time
the guilt-free guide to life balance
is my co-host today as we talk about
your life and your money
you can get that book anywhere number
one best sellers are sold including
ramseysolutions.com
sam is in phoenix hi sam welcome to the
ramsey show
hi how you doing thank you for taking my
call sure what's up
um let's see i'm blessed i've got about
uh 1.7 million in my retirement ira
account good for you wow
thank you
uh got about 150 k in cash available
annual salary about 180 and also from
military retirement and from another
company retirement about 80 000 a year
as well wow
only that we have is uh mortgage 270 k
and the health score is about 900k
financial advisor very reputable edelman
financials
been with them for quite a few years and
uh they also uh
follow the ramsey methodology if you
will but recently they've had a couple
of articles about nothing the mortgage
because of uh the return on investments
and uh the low interest rate our
interest rate is about two and eight
and last year um our accounts make close
to thirty percent
question is should we pay off the
mortgage we can pay it off in about two
to three years or
invest more when uh in our retirement
accounts okay well let's be real clear
that article had nothing to do with the
ramsey method
correct there's never been a ramsey
method that suggested that
right okay i just want to make sure that
our audience didn't misunderstand that
sam you've done really well
the answer to this question is not going
to mess up your life
and it's not going to make your life
awesome where it's not awesome now
okay
it's more of a technical question and a
viewpoint question
all right
now i i can give you a a a two-hour
dissertation on this but i'm not going
to that's not fair
um the bottom line is when you look at
your home
as a borrowing on your home as a way to
make money on investments
that is not including mathematically
risk
now you're not taking a ton of risk
because you're not going to lose your
home in your financial situation if you
get in trouble on that mortgage you just
take some money from somewhere it might
hurt a little bit but you take it and
just pay it off you're not going to lose
the house so you don't have a ton of
risk but debt always
theoretically spiritually represents
risk
always
and if you don't believe me just think
about what if you owed
900 000 on this house instead of 200 000
then you would say well that's more risk
than i have today well debt represents
risk you see what i'm saying
yes yes so uh when you say i'm going to
compare my investment returns to my
mortgage cost you're leaving out
mathematical adjustment for risk
so from a sophisticated standpoint the
formula that the blogger you were
talking about is using is naive because
it it does not include risk
and it is not realistic to think you're
going to make 30 on your investments
long term that is not a long term number
you may have done that for a short
period of time but you and i both know
over a 10 20 year period of time that's
not what the market returns it's not
going to do that with any financial
advisor
anybody that tells you that's full of
crap
so um but so so the normal stock market
returns are you know around 10 to 12
something like that over a period of
time versus mortgage rates so when you
adjust that for risk you're you might be
making a little bit of money now here's
how you can kind of prove that theory
let's pretend for a second that your
home was paid for that you had no debt
on it
okay right breathe that into your spirit
just a second
yep
then someone comes to you and says hey
sam
let's take your paid for 900 000 home
and let's borrow 500 000 on it and put
it in the markets
because you can make more on it there
than your mortgage rate
when i say that does your stomach not
jump into your throat just a little bit
yes
yeah and see that tells you that you
know your heart
is where you measure risk your head is
where you do math
and that jump of your stomach is a human
reaction to risk
and so when you reverse engineer your
question meaning let's pretend your
house was paid for would you go borrow
on it it's the same math so sure you
would matter of fact you if you're going
to use only i can make 30 and i pay 4
then you would borrow 2 million on your
1 million house
if that's the only math you're using but
when you say that out loud the risk
starts ringing in your ears and you know
that's not right anymore but with it
only being two hundred thousand out of
nine hundred thousand out of a three
million dollar net worth it sounds like
uh it's not much risk so it doesn't
really ring in your ears and you can
reduce you can real quickly reduce it to
only a naive math formula so all of that
to say
i would challenge you to pay off your
house
tomorrow as fast as you possibly can now
if i'm wrong and you hate it
you can always go get you a new mortgage
right all right and i'll tell you here's
what's going to happen what do you do
for a living
i spent 33 years as an engineer now i'm
consulting as an engineer after i
retired from that company and you were
in the military
and uh 28 years military yes thank you
for your service
number one when we did a study of 10 000
millionaires number one profession
of a millionaires in america engineer
okay
and so you you fit the mold exactly of
everyday millionaires of the study that
we did we found lots of people look just
like you
and so
um
here's the thing the the process
that you have used is what made you
wealthy not the rate of return
yep
your steadiness
your consistency
and you as an engineer looked at the
spreadsheets and said i'm going to keep
doing this you recognizing compound
interest when you saw it
this is what made you wealthy it was not
the rates of return it was not that i i
made an extra half a percent over here
playing this game or i made a quarter of
a percent spread over here i made a two
percent spread over there that wasn't
what made you wealthy what made you
wealthy was steadiness
consistency
process systems
that you had in place because that's the
way your brain works
and that's what that's why these
engineers that's why teachers are number
three because they are used to doing a
lesson plan yeah and following the
lesson plan they get the process so sam
i'd pay it off that's what i would do
well i love how you walked through that
dave because i've never heard you walk
through the emotional piece of it of
like well let's reverse engineer this
and how do you feel the idea of going
out and taking out a loan on your paid
for house it makes your heart jump in
your throat but i think the the feelings
the spirit of it is important for people
to pay attention to
because this idea of the burden of debt
the burden of owing someone else the
burden of those payments there's
something going in your spirit where it
just feels wrong and when you're free of
that
you don't want to ever go back so we can
justify it while we're in it because
we're used to it but if you could get
out of it if you're a person of faith
and you hear proverbs 22
rituals over the poor the borrower is
slave
to the lender
if that doesn't kind of grab you around
the throat just a little bit and go
all right i know technically i'm not at
submitting myself to slavery but
mathematically i am
uh there's a risk involved that's what
you know i'm making different decisions
because i do
because here's the interesting thing
even someone that is as systematic
systems driven as sam is i mean sam's a
numbers guy like me he's going to have a
a reaction when he gets this house paid
off that he doesn't see coming right
he's going to feel like i just got set
free there's going to be a little little
moment
now for those of us that are a little
more emotional a little less systems it
might be a big moment right it might be
like fireworks and stuff go off yeah but
it's like i'm free you know that whole
debt-free scream thing right
and but there's gonna be like i didn't
even realize i had this little tight
place right below my right shoulder
blade right and all of a sudden it's
gone yeah it's not it does manifest
itself physically in your body talks
about that but there's a sense of
release yes when you have no
payments
of any kind
anywhere that's exactly what you were
talking about yeah because you get so
used to the payments and so used to the
normal you don't question it until
you're set free you're like oh i didn't
even realize i felt like that didn't
even realize i was a slave that's right
because i had a fairly
you know tolerant master right right
fairly easy master yep but then when i
was free i went
i did have a master yeah now i don't
that's right
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice
i'm dave ramsey your host kristy wright
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author a couple times over
is my co-host today her new book is a
number one take back your time the
guilt-free guide
to life balance and her 2022 gold
planner is on sale at
ramseysolutions.com today as well
be sure and check us out here the phone
number triple
five
825-5225
in phoenix hi eric how are you
how are you guys doing today great
what's up
hey listen um dave the question that i
have for you is um
my wife and i were very financially
stable we are not in debt with the only
debt we have is our home
um we donate a lot of money to to
charities and
try to be philanthropic and follow you
know the past but my mom um i'm a
product i'm a single child from the
product of a single mom
and uh my stress is
that you know she doesn't really have
savings she still works at 78 she's an
artist
and they don't call them starving
artists for
any other reason that they're starving
so the question that i have is
do you set money aside knowing you're
going to have to help them
um do i scale back on giving
to nonprofits and my wife runs a food
bank
so do we scale back on that and put
money aside knowing that something is
we'll have this in the future and i
don't know how far in the future but at
some point
yeah this is hard i mean this is one of
those things where i like that you're
asking the question eric because it
shows that you want to be intentional
and i would love to tell you there's a
formula of here's exactly how you handle
these family relationships and giving
but that's more um unique to each person
each family situation um and even your
values with you and your spouse one of
the things that i think um
is good that you're thinking about in
advance is well let me ask you this have
you talked to your mom about her
financial situation have you talked to
her about your concerns for her
well-being and her ability to you know
provide for herself in the future have
you all had those conversations
yeah but she's you know she's super
proud independent person and
she she would never ask for help that
says it's not it's not in her nature to
do that it's just uh well i'll just
basically keep working till i die kind
of thing and obviously as you know
and only child that's not you don't want
to see that you know what i mean she she
deserves to
um you know set sail just like everybody
else did or does and there you know my
wife and i were in the finance world for
a total of 47 years between the two of
us um i i'm very well
uh prepared to have strong conversations
and have it's just a matter of getting
your parent who you're still the child
even i'm 53 you know uh to listen to you
it's that's and then it becomes
like more of a fight you know yeah it's
really it's it's really weighs on me
yeah what's your what's your net worth
uh probably but uh we're probably around
maybe six million okay
here's what i would say if i were you
i would go ahead and understand and
accept and expect that's what i meant to
say expect
that she's going to do what she wants to
do
she's 78.
she's going to do what she wants to do
she's done what she's wanted to do her
life she's independent she's not going
to have you tell her what to do
you and your wife sit down and decide
how much you want to contribute to
taking care of her now or in the future
and you just plan on it that's what i
would do i would just i would just
if i were you pick a number
and then y'all get and this could just
be between you and your spouse and you
don't even need it right now she's she's
doing what she's doing but when the
opportunity rises right now when she
needs it
then you're then you're ready and
prepared to take care of your single mom
mother as the only child i'm in this um
you know i can relate to you eric in
that sense if i feel a deep
responsibility to my mom because i am an
only child and um and she's been by
herself for for decades
and so i get that
i think that that to expect her to do
anything than other than what she's done
for 78 years is setting you and her up
for disappointment instead i would just
decide she's going to do what she's
going to do and i'm going to decide with
my spouse how much we want to contribute
to taking care of her and when you need
to then you've got the money i don't
know dave i don't know what the right
answer is to this that's what that's
what my good news in your situation is
you're not going to have to help her
enough that it's going to affect you at
all you've done so well
i mean think about it i mean how much
you're gonna give her i mean yeah you
know if you gave her 50 000 a year for
10 years it doesn't change your life a
bit
right
you'll be fine i mean and you don't have
to have a special fund to do that you
got six million dollars
yeah well i still think of you know
obviously we still have a lot of time
before we retire and yeah but we have
two daughters that are getting ready to
dude you got six million dollars you're
all right
you're okay
you're gonna be okay
and you come out of the financial world
you understand that you're 53 and at 60
that's gonna be 12 million dollars
yeah right and by the way she's only 85
at that point
and so you know the her life expectancy
mathematically and the amount of money
you would if you set her up in
fairly lavish lifestyle actually it
isn't even going to show up
all right
it's going to be fine now what you do
need where it is going to show up is in
emotions
and so you need to establish what
emotions you're going to have and your
wife is going to have towards your mom
and so if it happened at my house it'd
be the exact same kind of conversation
it really wouldn't matter to us
mathematically
we could support someone like that in
that situation and not even notice we're
in a good you know
higher net worth than you so it wouldn't
be a big deal it's not a big deal for
you you can do it now but what would
matter is how sharon felt about it
that would matter a lot and that could
cause a lot more trouble than the math
yeah she's my wife is far more
level-headed than i
i am we're i'm from back east and i
don't know how many people you know that
have relationships like my mom and my
relationship i mean uh we're not italian
but we might as well be as far as yeah
you're you're screaming when you're
having a conversation yeah well i mean
it's you know hillbilly's cajuns
italians we all fight it's our love
language
you know so uh same thing i get that
part so but the uh but here's the thing
i wouldn't worry about your mom i'm with
christy on that i don't think you're
gonna change her at this point she's
she's setting her ways what i would have
is a simple 10 minute conversation with
your wife and say
when we get the call
and mom's gonna start needing support
not if
but when
i mean the only way you won't get that
call is if she passes away before she
runs out of money right or energy to
make money let's see otherwise you're
gonna get this call so when we get this
call
what is our annual budget for mom both
of you agree to that tonight over dinner
it's a 10 minute conversation
i think she can make it on four grand a
month okay it's 48 000 a year we're
going gonna commit to that when we get
the call we're both okay we've already
decided we're on one page then mom's
gonna eventually wander around to the
end of her art and end of her money and
you're gonna have to feed her and it's
not gonna matter 48 000 a year when you
got 6 million bucks it's not spit that's
the beautiful thing
about walking these baby steps and
becoming a millionaire way to go nathan
you're a hero you live like no one else
later you can live and give like no one
else
touchdown
eric yes eric
it wasn't nathan that's all right it was
gary i'm right here there you go here
for you nathan you're you're a hero too
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 thousand dollars about two
years after that i got a remote job that
pays me hundred and thirty thousand
dollars all thanks to what i learned at
bethel tech you could be next get
started today at betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the ramsey show
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee means even if you miss measure
you pick the wrong color they'll remake
your blinds for free you get free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more use the promo code ramsey to
get the best deal
today's question comes from cole in
south carolina i'm 18 years old and have
an opportunity to buy a business for 85
000
the owner wants thirty thousand dollars
up front and will accept the other fifty
five thousand in monthly payments with
little to no interest until unless i
fail to pay on time i've saved fifteen
thousand but i would have to get a loan
for the other fifteen thousand to make
the down payment then i'd make monthly
payments as i make money from the
business itself
the business is seasonal so it'd be
during the summer while i'm not in
college the owner said that he makes
between 20 and 35 000 a year with the
business does this sound like a good
opportunity
i have so many follow-up questions no to
the loan obviously no you're not going
to get a loan for this down payment for
this business but i don't even i don't
even know what this business is i don't
know what they're talking about i don't
know
what the records show what are you
actually paying for
is this established client base and
brand i
just no cole no
i mean based on what i know no because
you'd have to get a loan but also i just
i don't know when when people come and
dave i'm curious how you how you vet
this
because i hear people ask a similar
question through the business boutique
academy hey i have an opportunity i have
an opportu a business opportunity and a
lot of times it's vague and they're just
gonna have to pay a bunch of money up
front but there's not a lot of details
that always is a red flag to me yeah
yeah
well i got a bunch of red flags um on
this too i agree with you the um
uh
red flag number one is you're you're
borrowing all of it yeah and you're
gonna get yourself in a pinch there
uh red flag number two is the owner
makes between 20 and 35 000 a year with
the business i don't think he does
i think that's the profit
and he
pays himself that
so i don't think this business has any
value
okay
what do you want bat yeah no no i bet
you i bet you i bet you that's what the
guy makes yeah yeah
and he wants to sell he he doesn't own a
business he owns his job right yep yep
because if he owned a business there's a
profit after the owner is paid
an operator's salary
yeah okay and so if you pay
and this is summer so what is this it's
a lawn care business right yeah okay
guy's got a lawn care business he's
making 30 grand on it and he wants to
sell this 18 year old kid his job
and you're buying a job yeah which you
could do on your own tomorrow for like
five hundred dollars we're gonna make 30
000 a year you could buy your own job
yes you know and you can do that for a
lot less than 85 000 yeah so no
because i think that's what this is yeah
no i wouldn't do it yeah no i wouldn't
go in debt to do it no i wouldn't buy a
business that does not make a profit
yeah after the owner has paid a
reasonable operator's salary yeah
and i'm guessing that that's what this
is if it's lawn care sun you could spend
a whole lot less
than the whole take just the money you
have in your pocket
you can be in business and you'll make
more than 35 000 and you won't have paid
anything for it you know it's so
interesting you got to go out there and
hustle up clients is all you got to do
that but that's the point i think it's
so interesting because so many people
uh business in a box i want this to be
easy that's what it is they're just they
feel like oh someone's gonna hand me
this thing and i don't have to do
anything no you're still gonna have to
do stuff but you could do that on your
own and you could make a lot more money
with little to no startup cost you could
start it tomorrow you could go get this
clients and start your
start your own lawn care or whatever
business coal uh for virtually nothing
and you could build this business and be
making more than this guy is uh most
likely yeah but i think so the answer is
do not do this deal yeah because i
promise you some number of assumptions
we're making in this are correct all
right
some of them aren't maybe
but
some of them are correct and i'm even
gonna go there yes i'm gonna go there
you ready yeah i'm ready you're 18. i
was thank you thank you i was
you're 18. okay there's not not uh 18
year olds aren't stupid 18 year olds
aren't a problem but you have zero
life and business experience and walking
out there and buying an 85 000 business
with zero
life and business experience means you
getting ready to get your head chopped
off boy
that's what's coming you're gonna get
your head smacked and uh i'm sorry that
sounds like ah dave doesn't like young
people dave's an old fart you know well
that's part of that's all true but
but
you know here's the thing someone who
has 20 years business experience sees
business differently than someone who
has zero business and life experience
and that's not a slam on somebody
because they're young that's not the
point but the point is the younger you
are on this kind of thing by definition
the dumber you are on average me too by
the way you're younger and you don't
have the money so in summary cole you're
18 years old so you're drunk number two
you don't have the money for this and
number three it sounds like it's a bad
opportunity so no no and no three times
over now go get a job son go get a job
or start your own laundry you're in
college what do you want to do so you're
in college it's a summer job
you know you're a hustler you're a
grinder you're gonna go do something
good you're going to be fine but don't
go 85 000 in debt to buy this guy's job
no no no no no no no no no
nathan
there's nathan
nathan's a hero nathan's in london
ontario did you know you're a hero
nathan already called you a hero once
because i got the name wrong from the
other guy but anyway what's up man how
are you
i'm doing great how are you great hero
what's up
um so i'm gonna be turning 22 this year
and i have 21 000 dollars saved in my
savings way to go
i haven't invested it or done anything
with it and i'm going to be graduating
community college pretty soon good for
you what's your degree in the winter
time from electrical engineering
technology wow what are you going to do
after you graduate go on for further ed
or are you going to go into the
workplace
right away into the workplace
i'm pretty uncertain if i want to
go further ahead in education or not so
i'm just going to work to make money to
pay for
university if i decide to go to it i
like you um
my question is
when should i start investing my money
or start to save for a down payment for
a house um i'm just kind of pretty lost
in what to do next in my life
financially since i'm going to be
graduating soon um that's mainly my
question well you have done a great job
so far sir you're way ahead of the
typical guy out there your age you've
done really smart way to go
congratulations you are hero
see i was right okay there you go i was
a prophet that's right but uh so so
really cool so here's what we're going
to do as soon as you step out of school
let's start walking what we call our
baby steps have you ever heard christy
and i talk about those
yes okay so tell me what the first thing
you need to do is
um
get an emergency fund yeah you have no
debt right
yeah and then have no debt and then um
do you have any doubt three to six no i
do not have okay so you're already at
baby step three so three to six you got
it right you dialed it in so we're going
to set some of your 20 000 aside as your
emergency fund
and then we're going to set some of it
aside to start saving towards your house
and then you can sit down with a
smartvestor pro or an investment advisor
in your area we don't have them in
canada so you can find an investment
advisor in your area that has the heart
of a teacher and you can um start your
investing right baby step four
while you're saving for your house
all right any idea what kind of money
you're gonna be making
um it's about 78 000 a year um i'm a
pretty motivated person i think i
i have the drive to make more than that
by going to university afterwards but um
i'm kind of
um you know thinking about if i need a
degree or not to actually
get make the money i'd like to so i'm
just going to work for a year and see
what i feel and you know what during
that year if you want to not do baby
step four not do retirement instead pile
up cash because we not might want the
money for them for a university move
uh that would probably be a good idea
because honestly you're a better
investment than a retirement account is
and you're not sure right now you're not
sure what you're going to do because
you're young and you're in transitional
years of your life so yeah you can pile
up money and then you can use it for
college use it for university use it for
a house you'll have it for whatever you
decide to do
so cool well done sir very well done
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage tyson and taryn are with
us hey guys how are you great good how
are you better than i deserve where do
you guys live amarillo texas oh welcome
to nashville good to have you and all
the way over here to do a debt-free
scream how much have you paid off uh 395
000 in six years whoa
i love it and your range of income
during that six years i think we started
at 92 000 and now up to 230. cool what
do y'all do for a living
i'm a critical care pharmacist and a
professor at a school of pharmacy
and i'm a substantial electrician for a
local utility here in texas wow both of
you killing it excellent excellent so
i'm guessing six years 3.95 you paid off
the house that's it
look at the weird people y'all are
amazing how old are you two uh 32 and 31
with a paid for stinking house
i love you
you're amazing how much is this house
worth uh we just had a realtor pull it
it's now worth 430.
wow and you're 32 and 31 31 32 and 31
years old oh my gosh that is so cool all
right tell me this six year story what
in the world how'd you get plugged into
ramsey and what'd you do
so i uh i started listening to you on
the am radio when uh i was driving a
tractor making 10 bucks an hour and uh
saved up about 70 grand i was actually
planning on uh
paying cash for a house and then i met
this young lady who was in pharmacy
school which is not cheap so
yeah i had actually i had heard of you
but i hadn't really heard about the
college stuff so i i took out student
loans to go to pharmacy school and that
was a hundred thousand of that
um so when we got married i started you
know working at it while i was in
residency and then when we got married
we chunked the 70 000 at it and then
kept chipping away from there so really
the the rest of that was over six months
and then the rest was the house so six
months you knocked out your debt yes and
then you built your emergency fund
walked right up the baby steps yes sir
and so you've been saving 15 while
you're doing this yes sir all right very
well done amazing so how much is in your
retirement accounts i think right now
it's over 200 issues okay so you're
going to be millionaires before you know
it yes almost there yes and you're 32
years old you're almost baby-step
millionaires already that's incredible i
love these guys that's incredible
yeah
very cool substation electrician and
pharmacy
critical care pharmacist and professor
yeah very well done i love it great
great fields of work great study way to
go
you guys are so weird all right
now
how many people
through the last six years have told you
all how weird you are and how stupid you
are and how off-track you are and you're
crazy it's been about eighty percent of
the people we know
there's another twenty are like what are
you doing and then they're the ones that
are listening right now so yeah so yeah
we got made fun of a little bit during
residency and we had we actually used
like the envelope system with cash so we
got made fun of for that a little bit
yeah
yeah
the people that made fun of you need to
understand you're 32 years old with a
paid paid-for house and you're almost
millionaires shut up
yeah i love it
wow pretty cool wow you guys are
impressive yes sir so you and you they
seem so calm i know so chill about the
fact that they have a paid for house and
i'm almost millionaires yeah
so uh what do you tell people the secret
is now that you've done this stuff and
you paid off your house and you're
rocking it for me it was uh definitely
the budget um the envelope system was
awesome and then we got plugged in with
every dollar and you know that just
turned it on high drive you know if you
can't find ten dollars extra in your
budget to pay for the every dollar plus
like there's something wrong you're not
using it right so that that kicked it
into high gear for us a lot yeah and i
think for for me it's just knowing that
you can do it no matter what your income
is that sounds easy for us to say
because we have really good incomes now
but
when i started i was making 40 000 as a
resident and i paid off a small car loan
before we got married and then started
chipping away at the student loans and
so
it's it's really inspiring to hear all
the other debt free screams where they
make less than us and they paid off the
same amount just might take a little bit
longer but i think it's just kind of
believing that you can do it having the
discipline
yeah that's good wow that's good well
the typical person takes them two years
to get through baby step two you did
that in six months and it takes them
seven to eight years to pay off their
home and you did that in five years and
a half absolutely amazing yeah you guys
are overachievers
also want to mention that uh we cash
flowed two kids our our sons baron and
jacob couldn't be here today and number
three is on the way oh congratulations
thank you very much very good good for
you congratulations very good so very
very very powerful so talk to someone
who's getting criticized by their
friends
it's worth it
it's 100 worth it uh being weird is is
uh it's hard to do but
it's
the payoff is
is big yeah yeah and during this five
years you guys have have been you've not
been on beans and rice the whole time
you just for that six months right yes
sir and then you've just been steady yes
really it's just being intentional and i
mean we took a few trips too we went to
ireland after we paid off the student
loans and before we had kids and then we
went to disney world when we got to
around 200 000 on the house and so we've
kind of you know done things longer
yeah a hundred thousand i think we went
to new york so setting those milestones
was really celebrating along the way yes
absolutely very cool very cool all good
this is a marathon this is a marathon
not a sprint so that's good once you get
past that baby step three then you get
go from intense to intentional and you
that so those of you that are yolo and
you're like i don't want to live um
beans and rice my whole life shut up
your little immature whining they didn't
they went to freaking ireland okay
so just just just just to put the
whiners to rest out there you guys are
awesome yeah i just love you absolutely
fabulous incredible incredible
incredible well we got a copy of the
legacy journey for you that's the next
step in your process and uh we're so
proud you're about to be baby steps
millionaires right on your way just
following them right along and right on
schedule very well done copy the total
money makeover you can give away to one
of the naysayers or to somebody who
you're cheering along now either one
whatever you need to do there use it how
you want it's for you to gift away and
to pay it forward with
pretty incredible couple yeah that's
amazing yeah rockstars tyson and taran
amarillo texas 395 000 paid off in six
years that's their house and everything
32 and 31 be millionaires in about 20
more minutes
92 to 230 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one we're dead free
[Applause]
that's another milestone very good
way to go you
guys got to tell you uh
if you're 52 you can do this too
if you're 62 you can do this too but it
is particularly cool when someone see if
they're 32 they started six years ago so
they started at 26. yeah um
and uh
i mean mathematically they should be
millionaires literally in
probably 24 to 36 months yeah that's
about where they'll be yeah and so by
the time they're 35 yeah we'll just put
it at that and um see this is what you
can do
well not in america today there's
systemic economic problems that's
because you're a socialist if you say
stuff like that so there's not systemic
economic problems there's systemic
problems but people like this are heroes
who overcome them there's systemic every
kind of problem out there it's called
the human race
they can screw up christmas but then you
run along and find a hero like this that
says in spite of the challenges
in spite of naysayers
in spite of someone saying i'm weird i
can still do this and it turns out you
believing you can is one of the biggest
factors yeah that's that's the first
step and i want to connect it back to a
call we had a little while ago of of
someone asking why should i pay off the
home early and then we had another call
of hey we want to take care of our aging
you know mother-in-law it's like when
you pay off the home early when you're
completely debt-free when you become a
millionaire so that
you can do whatever you want to you can
go to ireland you can take care of your
mother you can
you can give generously there is a so
that to this it's not paid off just to
pay it off yes that's wonderful but it
frees you
to do whatever you want to do the rest
of your life with all of your money and
it just that i think people miss the why
afterwards sometimes and think about
these guys with little kids they got
little kids yes and money yes yeah
little kids in money i mean you can do
stuff with little kids yeah most people
when they're raising little kids are
starving today
and the little kids endure that part of
the life but these people got money with
little kids yeah that's a different
thing i mean that's a disney fast pass
yeah yeah it is it's a different kind of
experience you different kind of life
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day john 10 10 the
thief comes only to steal and destroy
i have come that they may have life and
have it more abundantly
albert einstein said weakness of
attitude becomes weakness of character
oh i have not heard that out of his
mouth
that's a good one weakness of attitude
becomes
weakness of character
you know i i'm um
[Music]
doing some writing and and one of the
things i was just writing about was
belief
and in that everyday millionaire study
uh we found that 97
of the 10 000 millionaires that we
studied that's all of them okay it's
almost 100
said that they believed that they
largely control their own destiny in
today's america
and we did the same survey with the
general public
and only 61 percent said they believe
they largely control their own destiny
oh wow
so
and it's a simple thing it's not a
matter of positive thinking solves
everything because uh i do believe that
if you think positively that's a good
thing versus thinking negatively glass
effects better than i mean abundance is
better than scarcity these are kinds of
basic ideas but
but you can't i can't positive think
myself into being
in the nfl i'm 61
and i'm not going to play in the nfl
no matter how much positive thoughts
i've had so that's ridiculous yeah but
but i but the concept of believing that
i can do something
and and the old motivator earl
nightingale used to said what i can
conceive
and believe
meaning i understand it and
and i can see how it's going to work
and therefore i believe it then i can
achieve it i can do it um
and so
if you believe the lies in the political
landscape
that
all rich people inherit their money
which is a lie most don't
if you believe that the little man can't
get ahead if you believe that because
you're a race a certain race you
can't overcome those obstacles of racism
racism is real if you believe that
because you're a woman you can't
overcome sexism sexism is real if you
believe that
whatever your thing is your barrier is
is greater than your ability to overcome
it therefore
the you do not have the opportunity to
do it you can't do it
then you've established yourself as a
victim
of that
ism
of that barrier
that lack of belief
causes you to do zero towards going to
win right so 100 of the time the lack of
belief causes you to not win well it's
interesting because when i've talked
about this before either in my content
on building confidence or even like my
fear talk at business boutique and that
type of thing is and i use the you know
the classic henry ford quote of if you
think you can or you can't you're right
but what it's what we're really breaking
this down to is
if you don't believe it's possible
whatever it is building wealth getting
ahead in your career starting your
business if you don't believe that it's
possible
then you won't try and then you don't
but it's not because it wasn't possible
it's because you didn't take action
which started in your beliefs and so i i
always you know you and i both have told
the story of the four-minute mile the
fascinating part about the four-minute
mile is not that john landy or not that
uh robert bannister roger bannister
broke it it was that
six weeks later it was broken by john
landy it was broken two more times that
year and it's been broken 500 times
since when high schoolers run four
minutes what had never been done is now
the standard
because people saw that it was possible
and so it really does come down to
believing something's possible even if
you haven't seen it because you will
begin to take action in the direction of
making it happen you'll find a way to
make it work you'll find ways around the
obstacles you'll come up with creative
ideas because you believe it's possible
if you don't then why in the world would
you put effort and energy into being
into something that's impossible it's
insane to do yes it's insane to put
effort and energy to something that and
sacrifice for something that's
completely it's going nowhere that's
completely impossible and so that's
what's evil
and dangerous
about these
people peddling
uh the idea that the little man can't
get ahead the idea that it's impossible
to prosper in america today with the
current systems so the systems are all
broken why do you think that's so
popular and so prevalent why why is that
why does it because it gives me an
excuse to lose yeah gives me an excuse
to quit and i didn't really have the
energy
and the courage and the backbone and the
intestinal fortitude to get up off my
assumptions and go do something
and uh and and so if you want to be a
couch potato
now you've got a now you've got a
narrative you've got an excuse you got a
narrative that makes it okay because
well i'm such and such and people like
me you know they don't win
and the problem with your theory when
you've got that narrative is there's
people like you that have one yeah yeah
that have already proven your narrative
wrong yeah well it becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy it does if you
if you that that's my point
is it's not the power of positive
thinking it is the power of belief
because belief says
i don't know exactly how i can get there
but i can see that if i save 15 of my
income if in good growth stock mutual
funds how that's going to turn into a
million dollars that's a mathematical
thing i could see how that's going to
happen and so i'm going to do that
i can see how if i pay extra on my house
when i'm 32 i'm going to have a paid for
house in amarillo texas
as an electrician substation and my
wife's a pharmacist you know i mean i
can see how i'm going to be able to do
that
and and when you can conceive it see it
then you start taking the action then
when all the naysayers start coming at
you you're like
you guys can't do math yeah i mean
what's wrong with you people yeah you
can't do math because you you don't have
some kind of false belief it's not uh
some kind of puffed up
dreamland skittles and rainbows thing
right it's it's a based on a reality
right and it's like you know the first
time i ever ran five miles
without stopping
i knew
i could do 13.
yeah and when i did nine
i knew i could do a full marathon yeah
once i did a couple of 13 halves i
really knew i could do a full yes and
there's something powerful in that
when you do something hard you do
something new you do something you've
never done before where the result is
you surprise yourself and at the end of
that five miles your natural thought is
what else can i do that i'm not aware of
and you start dreaming bigger dreams and
going for bigger goals and you go i can
do a half marathon i can do a full
method there's something so powerful and
pushing yourself outside your comfort
zone where the result is you surprised
yourself i didn't know i could do that
what else can i do that i'm not aware of
that that experience you just described
is so powerful and moving people into
into doing things they never thought
they could do becoming a millionaire
running a marathon atomic habits and
some of these other pieces of research
that are out there
um and deloney could probably chime in
on this big time there's something about
our spirits our psychology our emotions
our spiritual walk um even our intellect
that once it is stretched to a certain
point it cannot return to the same shape
that's good because you know the second
million
they always say it's easier to make
second million than first why
i know i can do it i've already done it
that's right i mean you know first i
mean i i'd be highly disappointed if i
went out to run a half marathon now if i
didn't complete it right
i mean and i'm not in training for one
right now i'm not gonna go do it but i
mean i i've run i don't know 20 25 of
those things and and if i set out and
did the training exercise if i didn't
i've never not completed one right and
it wouldn't it just doesn't occur to me
but the first time right
i thought i was gonna die
and i and i knew i was crazy about the
ninth mile yeah you know there's a whole
bunch of crazy people around me doing
the same thing running this race you
know but but then when i finished i'm
like it wasn't long before your brain
starts going i think i'm thinking i'm
gonna do this again that's right i'm
gonna do this again because you've had
the success the brain craves traction
and you you know you never reach the
point that you go i can't do it again
right because you know because you've
done it that's what that's what builds
confidence people think that confidence
is this feeling it's a certain gene
people are born with i'm like no it's
really comes down to courage where you
act courageous you do it scared you push
yourself outside the comfort zone you do
that first half marathon once you
survive it because you will
well then you have proof and go i can do
that so i know i can do it again your
second one you're confident approaching
that second one because you have proof
you've done it before but it started
with just trying just putting yourself
out there and being courageous and after
a while you're like now when i first
walked on my first stage as a public
speaker i was scared out of my mind now
i'm confident it's through the
experience of doing it it doesn't occur
to you that you won't be able to do a
good message
yeah and so belief does matter yeah
so you can be a baby steps millionaire
uh you can start from wherever you
whatever your dysfunctional screwed up
background whatever obstacles you've got
i know they're there i know they're real
i'm not saying they're not real i'm
saying you can do it anyway so get after
it
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker just
tell alexa google assistant or siri to
play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
[Music]
you